OUT.
THIS MIGHT BE THE DUMBEST TIME
TO BE ALIVE.
LET'S TURN IT OVER TO JORDAN
BELL FOR THE.
MOTIVATIONAL SPEAKER, KNOWN AS
THE WOLF OF WALL STREET.
JORDAN, DID YOU SEE MINI MADOFF
COMING?
WERE YOU ONE OF THE SMART GUYS?
>> WELL, I DIDN'T HAVE ANY MONEY
AT FTX.
I THINK THE WHOLE CONCEPT OF
WHAT FTX REPRESENTED, WHICH WAS
A BROKERAGE FIRM THAT YOU DON'T
KNOW HOW THEY ARE HOLDING MONEY
OVERSEAS OPERATIONS LIGHTLY
REGULATED.
I DIDN'T LOSE MONEY.
LISTEN, I WILL ADMIT THOUGH NOT
THAT I WAS FOOLED BY IT, BUT,
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING HOW MUCH FRAUD SOMEONE
IS COMMITTING UNLESS YOU CAN
LOOK INSIDE THEIR BOOKS.
>> Jesse: WHAT ABOUT IF WHAT
THEY ARE WEARING?
WHAT IF THE GUY HAS AFRO WITH
GYM SHORTS AND SHAKING LIKE
THIS?
>> THAT'S -- PEOPLE THAT
ACTUALLY DID DUE DILIGENCE THEY
ACTUALLY SHOULD HAVE THEIR HEADS
EXAMINED BECAUSE IF I WOULD HAVE
WALKED INTO THIS PLACE AND TAKEN
ONE LOOK AROUND, IT WOULD HAVE
TAKEN ME FIVE SECONDS FLAT TO
SAY THERE IS SOMETHING AMISS
HERE, THERE IS NO WAY THESE GUYS
ARE ON THE LEVEL.
HE WAS PLAYING VIDEO GAMES.
THEY ARE ALL BANGING EACH OTHER
IN SAM'S -- MORE LIKE A FRAT
HOUSE THAN A BUSINESS.
THE GUY TOOK OVER, RANGERS THE
RECEIVER IS SAYING LIKE IT IS
ALL -- HE HAS NEVER SEEN
SOMETHING SO NO GOVERNANCE, NO
CONTROLS.
HOW COULD ALL THOSE BIG
SOPHISTICATED FUNDS FROM SEQUOIA
ON DOWN GIVEN THIS GUY MONEY AND
NOT PICKED UP ON ANY OF THIS?
THAT, I DON'T KNOW.
>> Jesse: HE HAD BEDS IN THE
BEDROOM AND BOARD ROOM WAS IN
THE BAHAMAS A TAX HAVEN.
NOW HE IS COMPLAINING THAT HE
DOESN'T HAVE A PROPER VEGAN DIET
BEHIND BARS.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT'S GOING TO
SHAKE OUT?
I WOULDN'T BE SO CONCERNED ABOUT
MY DIET IF I WAS IN A JAIL IN
THE BAHAMAS.
>> I KNOW A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THIS.
SO, HE IS FACING A REALLY LONG
TOUGH ROAD HERE.
AND THE VEGAN DIET OR LACK
THEREOF IS THE LEAST OF HIS
PROBLEMS.
IS HE GOING TO SPEND A COUPLE OF
YEARS IN PROBABLY EITHER
METROPOLITAN RECEPTION CENTER IN
BROOKLYN OR MCC IN MANHATTAN.
IT IS NOT FUN THERE.
THEY JUST LOCK 23 HOURS A DAY
UNTIL HE ULTIMATELY GETS
SENTENCED.
HE WILL PROBABLY GET 50 YEARS.
SOMETHING PRETTY SERIOUS LIKE
THAT.
>> Jesse: YOU WERE IN PRISON FOR
A LITTLE WHILE.
HE IS FACING SOME HARD TIME.
FROM SOMEONE THAT'S HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE, DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADVICE FOR MINI?
YOU MOW, HOW TO STAY OUT OF
TROUBLE IN PRISON?
>> FIRST, HE HAS TO SHUT UP.
HE HAS DIARRHEA OF THE MOUTH.
SHOCKING THEY ARRESTED HIM
YESTERDAY.
LIKE STOPPING A WITNESS IN MID
CONFESSION.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THEY DID.
THE GUY IS SPILLING HIS GUTS,
ABOUT TO SPILL HIS GUTS IN FRONT
OF CONGRESS.
I WONDER IF THERE WAS ANY
PRESSURE PUT ON HIM BY THE BIDEN
DOJ.
I MEAN, COME ON, JESSE.
THE GUY IS ABOUT TO TESTIFY AND
SAY -- EVERYBODY ALL THE PEOPLE
HE DONATED TO SO THEY ARRESTED
HIM?
ONCE HE GETS TO THE U.S. THOUGH,
HE IS IN FOR SOME SERIOUS PAIN.
HE NEEDS TO SHUT UP.
THAT'S WHAT HE NEEDS DO IS SHUT
UP AND LISTEN TO HIS LAWYERS.
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHA